hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
examples that William James provides in
pragmatism lecture - that could be a bit
confusing for some readers has to do
with what he calls the absolute and it's
closely connected with religion God
beliefs moral holidays all sorts of
other topics as well as what the
pragmatist point of view on this would
be and in order to put this in context
it's useful to remind ourselves that you
know James is writing at the cusp of the
19th and 20th centuries he's very
literate he's part of the Harvard
community so he's part of the you know
sort of on the cutting edge of the
literary and philosophical and
scientific developments of the times and
so he's considering something that is
becoming more and more popular as
previous considerations and
understandings of religion are not
necessarily going away certainly being
challenged and pushed to the margins
within the educated set so he talks
about present-day
idealism and
here he has in mind the you know
movement that starts out in Germany
among which you know Immanuel Kant and
Georg Friedrich Willem Hegel and you
know by that time as well they're
they're getting to know Schopenhauer and
of course they've got some other people
in there as well
our you know very important figures and
created new systems and approaches to
philosophy now a lot of Americans went
to be educated in Germany came back
having learned that German philosophy
and a lot of Germans brought it over
here to America we can talk for example
about the st. Louis high galleons
and so there's all this this confluence
all this this connection between that
around the same time you know the the
British establishment has quite a few
big aliens in it as well and you know
idealism had been in Britain for quite a
while Coleridge was one of the early
people to get it started so there's
there's a long rich history there and he
talks about this present day fashioned
of idealism and he says that this is not
very appealing to many people why
because it's too intellectualist
intellectual istic right and he says
old-fashioned theism that you know sort
of what we would call just traditional
religion was bad enough with its notion
of God as an exalted monarch made up of
a lot of unintelligible or preposterous
attributes but so long as it held
strongly by the argument from design it
kept some touch with concrete realities
it could satisfy the ordinary person
indeed the educated person's beliefs
they could say yeah I'm a Presbyterian
or I'm a Congregationalist or I'm you
know a Lutheran and you know these ideas
could hold some sway in their mind but
then he says since Darwinism is
displaced design from the minds of the
scientific theistic some kind of
imminent or pan theistic deity working
in things rather than above them is if
any of the kind recommended to our
contemporary imagination so aspirants to
a philosophic religion turn as a
oli says more hopefully towards
idealistic
pantheism rather than the older
dualistic the--is 'm in spite of the
fact that the latter has defenders now
what is this idealistic pantheism you
know and why is he contrasting it to a
dualism the idea is that the old-time
religion with a traditional conception
of God that we might find Satan Thomas
Aquinas or John Calvin right you've got
God the creator of the universe and then
you get everything else and God is
superior to everything else pantheism
says God is the everything else and
there's no else hey that's it everything
is in some way God and some things could
be more God some things could be less
God
but everything's God and then the
idealism is you know this this movement
of thought that James associates very
closely with the rationalistic temper
it's prone to working out systems and
and you know likes the absolute and it
tends to be very oriented towards
providing arguments and inferences that
everyone is supposed to be able to
accept but oftentimes it doesn't turn
out that way and so he says you know
this pantheism is kind of hard to
assimilate if you're a lover of facts or
empirically minded why well it has no
connection with concreteness affirming
the absolute mind which is its
substitute for God to be the rational
presupposition of all particulars of
fact it remains supremely indifferent to
what the particular facts in our world
actually are this is a big problem is it
not so he says be they what they are the
absolute will father them like the sick
lion in Aesop's fable all footprints
lead into his den but in air he says new
LaVista G over at foursome which is
Latin for there aren't any footprints
coming back out right and he says you
can't read ascend into the world of
particulars by the absolute aid or to do
sending necessary consequences of detail
important for your life from your idea
of his nature he gives you the assurance
that all is well with him and for his
eternal way of thinking but you're to be
finite we say
by your own temporal devices so what are
you saying here is you know can't seems
from a pragmatic point of view that this
this you know idealistic pantheism
doesn't have much to offer how's it
gonna help you how does being connected
with the absolute mind make your life
any better as he says then it seems
pretty remote pretty abstract right this
is a problem then now he says okay what
if we do look at it from a pragmatic
point of view what are people getting
out of all this talk about the absolute
or absolute spirit or mind you know
being vaguely a galleon Coleridge Ian
whatever other configuration of this
idealism that you want to give it he
says you know to begin with pragmatism
is not a materialism like empiricism
often tends to be and you know if we
think about what theological ideas do he
says theological ideas can be true and
in a sense if they have a value for
people's wives so if believing in this
even though it doesn't have any
practical consequences helps people out
that's a practical consequence you see
so you can you can say well even though
you can't verify the absolute even
though the absolute doesn't like do
anything apparently within within your
life believing in it makes you feel
better and that winds up being something
good so he says if our theological ideas
prove to have a value for concrete life
they will be true for a pragmatism but
in a certain sense not true in a
complete sense in the sense of being
good for so much and he goes on for how
much more they are true will depend
entirely on their relations to the other
truths that also have to be acknowledged
right so the absolute does in fact offer
comfort to quite a few people James is
not actually one of those people by the
way
but he's registering that it does for
others and he says what a believers in
the
mean when they say that their belief
affords them comfort here's where we get
into some real content some some actual
stuff what do they say he says they mean
that since in the absolute finite evil
is overruled already we may therefore
whenever we wish treat the temporal as
if it were potentially the eternal be
sure that we can trust its outcome and
without sin dismiss our fear and drop
the worry of our finite responsibility
in short they mean that we have a right
ever and anon
to take a moral holiday to let the world
wag in its own way feeling that its
issues are in better hands than ours and
are none of our business
this is very interesting because this
could just as well apply to the
classical theists
who has the gods mysterious ways they
know there's a divine providence great
plan you know even though the world
looks like crap and I seem to be
suffering quite a bit I can still say
well I don't need to do anything we can
have a certain kind of quiet ism that
will of God right or we can be you know
pantheistic idealistic absolutist
and say ah you know the world spirit is
moving I don't need to do anything it's
okay for me I don't have to feel crappy
about everything I can look around at
the suffering and say somehow all of
this is going to get redeemed it's all
gonna work out somehow there's a lot of
other perspectives by which people can
do this as well aren't there so that's
the kind of comfort and this is what
James calls taking a moral holiday which
is a very interesting phrase is it not
what does he mean by this moral holiday
he says the universe is a system of
which the individual members may relax
their anxieties occasionally in which
the don't care mood is also right for
men and moral holidays in order that is
I mistake not in is in part at least of
what the absolute is known as that is
the great difference in our own
particular experiences which is being
being true makes for us that is part of
his cash value
Winnie's pragmatically interpreted we
get to relax and think that things are
going to be okay now does that mean that
the absolute exists because people can
say don't worry be happy' or it's all
good or whatever catchphrase we want to
have right imagine of God it is a bit of
a digression imagine a God instead of
being composed of what James calls you
know these income in comprehensible
attributes instead it's a God of
catchphrases you know I got about which
we can say well you let's us save don't
worry be happy' or it's all good or
whatever else we want to have all these
cliches what a god that would be
wouldn't it now James goes on and he
says there's a little problem here
so truth if we want to say that truth is
what it would be better for us to
believe then then not to believe it
still has to jibe with the other things
that we think are true right so he says
that if there be any life that is really
better we should lead and if there be
any idea which if believed in would help
us to lead that life then it would
really be better for us to believe in
that idea unless there's a key provision
here right unless indeed belief in it
incidentally clashed with other gradle
greater vital benefits so are there any
other benefits that any other truths
provide that this notion of the absolute
would run into and you know James seems
to think there is he says that what is
better for us to believe is true unless
the belief clashes with some other vital
benefit in real life what vital benefits
is any particular beliefs of us most
liable to clash with what indeed accept
the vital benefits yielded by all their
beliefs when these prove incompatible
with the first ones in other words the
greatest enemy of any one of our truths
may be the rest of our truths truths
have once for all this desperate
instinct of self-preservation and a
desire to extinguish whatever
contradicts them so he says my belief in
the absolute based on the good it does
me thinking about moral holidays must
run the gauntlet of other beliefs are
there any things that clash with it he
says well you know when I look at my own
mental life I find this is not a very
plausible option for me why he says that
it happens to be associated with a kind
of logic of which I'm the enemy so I'm
already committed to something else and
I find that it entangles me in
metaphysical paradoxes that are
unacceptable so you know I'm not happy
with that either
and he says as I have enough trouble in
life already without adding the trouble
of carrying out these intellectual
inconsistencies I personally just give
up the absolute I just take my moral
holidays or as a professional
philosopher I try to justify them from
some other principle he says if I could
just restrict my notion of the absolute
to its bear holiday giving value it
wouldn't clash with my other truth
truths but we can't easily thus restrict
our hypotheses and here he has a
wonderful phrase they carry
supernumerary features and these it is
that clash so my disbelief in the
absolute means then disbelief in those
other supernumerary features for I fully
believe in the legitimacy of taking
moral holidays what are these other
supernumerary features all the other
commitments that come with buying into a
notion of the absolute that is coming
from you know idealistic pantheism and
and you know idealism in general James
says that's just not going to work for
me not only the absolute can clash with
other truths but it does but James is
willing to say that I mean it works for
other people and so it's true insofar as
it works for them just doesn't work for
me or people who are so constituted like
myself so you know can pragmatism
embrace this idealistic pantheistic
notion of the absolute yeah it depends
you know depends on what we're willing
to live with
and give up it can embrace it to a
certain extent and then say yeah there's
there's other things that are more
important that I need to hold on to
other truths that are more true in the
sense of being more vital more good that
will militate against accepting this
particular truth as true
you